Vorbereitungen in Vilnius morgen also
kommen hier die 31 Staats- und
Regierungschefs der NATO zusammen zur
Beratung über die noch ungeklärte
Gretchenfrage wie halten wir es nun mit
der Ukraine klar scheint allein ein
Beitritt ist aktuell keine Option die
Frage ist natürlich was passiert bis
dahin wenn sie NATO Mitglied ist dann
gilt für sie der Artikel 5 also die
beistandsklausel aber die Frage für die
Ukraine ist wie kann sie ihre Sicherheit
bis zu einem möglichen Beitritt
gewährleisten
eindeutige Zusagen forderte erneut
ukraines Präsident selenski für das
Treffen in Vilnius in einem Interview
mit dem US-Sender ABC
Ukraine sollte klare
Sicherheitsgarantien bekommen solange
sie nicht in der NATO ist und das ist
ein sehr wichtiger Punkt nur unter
diesen Bedingungen wäre unser Treffen
sinnvoll
ein bisschen Bewegung scheint es zu
geben aufhorchen ließ vor drei Tagen der
türkische Präsident Erdogan nach einem
Treffen mit selensk i mit der Aussage es
gebe keine Zweifel daran dass die
Ukraine die Mitgliedschaft in der NATO
verdient habe und bedeutsam vor allem
dies US-Präsident beiden stellte vor
seinem Abflug nach Europa in Aussicht
die USA könnten der Ukraine nach
Kriegsende und einem Friedensabkommen
einen ähnlichen Schutz bieten wie sie es
gegenüber Israel tun mit Geld und Waffen
schon ein etwas konkreterer Gedanke er
zeigt offenbar dass nato-treffen in
Vilnius soll möglichst nicht ergebnislos
enden
gleich begrüße ich dazu den ukrainischen
Botschafter in Deutschland vorher holen
wir uns noch eine kurze Einschätzung ab
und zwar von unserem für die NATO
zuständigen Korrespondenten Florian
neuhahn der bereits in der litauischen
Hauptstadt Vilnius ist Florian schön
guten morgen wird es denn von der NATO
ein eindeutiges beitrittsversprechen wie
von der Ukraine gefordert geben was
hörst du
das ist das Thema über das hier bis zur
letzten Minute offenbar heftig gerungen
wird und wo es bisher noch keine
Einigkeit gibt in der NATO es gibt
vereinfacht gesagt würde ich sagen zwei
Lager in der Allianz die einen angeführt
von den Osteuropäern wollen eben eine
klare Zusage aussprechen möglicherweise
auch mit einem Zeitplan oder eben eine
ganz klaren verbindlichen Einladung
die andere lade das andere Lage aber
wird angeführt von zwei nicht ganz
unwichtigen Alliierten nämlich den USA
und Deutschland die haben gerade bereits
gehört der US-Präsident gestern im
Fernsehen er sagte dort auch erhalte
diese ganze Debatte für voreilig und
auch die Ukraine für nicht reif genug
für eine Mitgliedschaft also das sind
die die große Konflikte zwischen diesen
beiden Lagern es könnte eine
Kompromisslinie geben dass man auf einen
sogenannten membership Action plant
verzichtet das heißt der Ukraine einen
verkürztes Verfahren anbietet so hat man
es bereits getan mit Finnland und auch
Schweden das ja weiterhin auf eine
Mitgliedschaft wartet aber die große
Frage ist ob das Ukraine ausreicht eine
Sicherheitsgarantie wie sie von Joe
Biden ins Spiel gebracht worden ist wird
sicher nicht ausreichend denn da wäre
die große Frage wie belastbar wäre eine
solche Garantie hatte den Namen Garantie
wirklich verdient
soweit die Einschätzungen von Florian
neuhahn live aus der litauischen
Hauptstadt wo morgen also der
NATO-Gipfel beginnt vielen Dank dafür
und damit jetzt zurück ins Studio und
hier begrüße ich jetzt olexe den
ukrainischen Botschafter in Deutschland
einen schönen guten Morgen guten Morgen
Herr Botschafter sie haben sich
ausgesprochen für ein eindeutiges
beitrittsversprechen was heißt das
konkret also seine Einladung der Ukraine
NATO beizutreffen und
Beitrittsverhandlungen zu beginnen wir
haben es in den letzten 500 Tagen klar
gezeigt dass Ukraine Natur reif ist und
das eigentlich heute keine das macht
wofür NATO eines Tages geschaffen war
der US-Präsident sieht das
offensichtlich anders wir haben gerade
von unserem Korrespondenten gehört der
US-Präsident sagt sie seien noch nicht
reif möglicherweise verweist er da auf
die Wirtschaftsleistung auf Korruption
und viele andere Dinge weil sie im Krie
sind und sich wehren das ist ja noch
kein sagen wir mal Merkmal dafür NATO
Beitritts nicht nur kandidats sondern
wirklich Mitglied zu werden ja das ist
keine Kleinigkeit natürlich dass wir in
ihrem Krieg sind und auch im Krieg
setzen wir unsere Formen fort und das
wird auch anerkannt von der Europäischen
Union und von NATO-Mitgliedstaaten es
ist keine einfache Aufgabe aber ich
glaube die ganze Welt und auch viele
hier in Deutschland haben heute
begriffen dass es heute keine bessere
Sicherheitsgarantie für Menschen gibt
als NATO-Mitglied man hätte das auch
hier begriffen das haben wir gerade
gehört gerade die USA und auch
Deutschland und damit der Bundeskanzler
sehen das offensichtlich anders und
sagen nein Beitrittskandidat auch nicht
nach Ende des Krieges bzw Mitglied das
wissen wir noch nicht es gibt noch so 48
Stunden für für die Gespräche weil diese
Entscheidung wird natürlich von
NATO-Mitglieder getroffen aber wir sind
sehr aufgeschlossen wir sind im Gespräch
auch mit Bundesregierung wir erklären
warum es für die Ukraine so wichtig ist
wir müssen auch daran erinnern dass 2008
beim bukarestar Gipfel Treffen von NATO
NATO Mitgliedsländer haben Schwäche
gezeigt und nicht der Ukraine und
Georgien einen klaren Weg zur NATO
Mitglied gegeben hat
Zeitfenster was schwierig ist weil der
kriegt keiner weiß wann der aufhört
niemand bestreitet das dass wir nicht
bevor
Ende des Krieges NATO-Mitglied werden
natürlich werden wir diesen Krieg
gewinnen müssen und dann mit allen
unseren Erfahrungen und unsere tollsten
Armee die auch eigentlich in der Zukunft
immer wieder
beistandsklausel folgen wird und andere
Länder auch schützen wird was würde das
überhaupt an der jetzigen Situation
verändern wenn morgen oder übermorgen
auf dem NATO-Gipfel wirklich die das
Verteidigungsbündnis dann sich einigt
und sagt ja okay die Ukraine kann in die
NATO nach Ende des Krieges ist es was
moralisches was was ihnen Hoffnung gibt
oder das das wird ein erster Schritt
einer neuen Sicherheitsarchitektur in
Europa sein 2008 nach dieser schwachen
Entscheidung hat Russland in ein paar
Monaten Georgien Überfall dann Ukraine
2014 wenn heute noch mal die Schwäche
zeigt wird gespannt
bestätigt dass eigentlich sie
Nachbarländer übergreifen kann und
Kriege führen kann deswegen brauchen wir
eine eine starke Botschaft
einer Sicherheitspartnerschaft die
bietet US-Präsident beiden ja
möglicherweise an sagt er und zwar in
Anlehnung an das was die USA auch mit
Israel vereinbart hat also da gibt es
sehr viel Geld bis zu 4 Milliarden
Dollar jedes Jahr dann konventionelle
auf und Hochrüstung atomare Bewaffnung
und das einbinden und die Teilhabe an
Wissen zum Beispiel auch von
Geheimdiensten und anderen sagen wir mal
auf anderen Ebenen auch die
Zusammenarbeit jenseits der
militärischen Fragen würde ihnen das
reichen das ist auch ein ein wichtiger
Teil von der ganzen Abmachung dass wir
auch Sicherheitsgarantien bekommen
müssen bis wir NATO Mitglied werden so
wie zum Beispiel und Schweden es
bekommen hat im
letzten Jahr die beste
Sicherheitsgarantie für heute
ist die Bewaffnung von ukrainischen
Truppen also die Sicherheitsgarantie
wollen Sie jetzt die Sicherheitsgarantie
oder Partnerschaft da geht die Wortwahl
durcheinander noch während des Krieges
dass man eine eindeutige Antwort und wo
sie gerade darüber gesprochen haben was
sie noch brauchen sie brauchen Munition
davon gibt es im Moment nicht genug die
Partner auch die USA kommen im Moment
nicht hinterher so viel zu produzieren
deswegen weichen die USA aus und werden
ihn Streubomben liefern ist das schon
fix bekommen Sie die und Streubomben das
wissen alle und deswegen aus guten
Gründen gibt es auch einen Übereinkommen
an dem Deutschland zum Beispiel
partizipiert wo man sagt wir Beteiligung
beteiligen uns nicht daran können Sie
eigentlich zu sichern dass sie die
Streubomben auch nicht aus deutschen
Haubitzen abschießen wir werden die
Streu Munition erstens nicht auf dem
territor im Russlands benutzen zweitens
nicht gegen Zivil Einrichtung wir sind
keine Russen da sind nur die Russen die
diese streuoben auf unsere Städten schon
seit 500 Tagen
geschossen haben drittens wir werden es
dort einsetzen und diese Gebiete
priorisieren für die mining also es gibt
ein klarer Plan was wir mit diesen
strömunitionen machen
möglicherweise abschließen denn das darf
Deutschland nicht zulassen nee das geht
nicht darum es geht nicht darum aus
welchen geschossen was geschossen wird
Deutschland hat versprochen Streu
Munition nicht zu benutzen und ich freue
mich sehr dass nach diesem langen
Wochenende
alle haben sich etwas beruhigt nachdem
wir erklärt haben was beabsichtigen wir
mit dieser Steuer noch gar nicht dazu
geäußert jedenfalls der
Verteidigungsminister will das erstmal
nicht Herr Botschafter vielen Dank für
Ihren Besuch heute vor dem für sie sehr
wichtigen nato-treffen in Vilnius was
morgen beginnt danke sehr gehen